- Remind your critics that
an amateur built the arc,
experts built the Titanic.
I always loved the game
and my dad loved to play,
he just taught me to play
the game for the love
of the game, that's really what I do.
There are other players
who are more talented,
but there was no one who
could out prepare me.
- We all speak regular
Gaelic, but Peyton's kind of
into his own thing, you know?
- He's a former American
football quarterback who played
18 seasons in the NFL.
He's considered to be one
of the greatest quarterbacks
of all time, he's the
only starting quarterback
to win a Super Bowl with
two different franchises.
He's Peyton Manning, and
here's my take for his top 10
rules for success.
Rule number one is a personal
favorite, and make sure
to stick around all the
way to the end for some
special bonus clips.
And as always if Peyton says
something that's really,
really meaningful to you,
please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around
it as he's talking so that
other people can be inspired as well.
- So don't let expertise silence you.
Work to find new
solutions to old problems.
Think outside of the
parameters that restrict
other people's thoughts.
Just because you're a novice
on the job, just because
you haven't faced the same
challenges, just because
you haven't climbed the
same cliffs, doesn't mean
that you can't contribute to solutions in
very significant ways.
When you're chided for your
naivete, and you will be,
remind your critics that
an amateur built the arc,
experts built the Titanic.
I think the fact that that
injury occurred to me has just
given me more of an
appreciation for this journey
that I'm on and I have had
fun this entire playoff.
I've tried to soak it up, I
haven't just been so laser
focused where I haven't enjoyed anything.
We'e had two good post
playoff win celebrations,
gave it a good run after
San Diego and a really good
run after New England, and I
think that's some advice that
some players in their older
years gave to me and I really
tried to follow that.
And I plan to enjoy this week as well.
We had a great week of preparation
last week, it's important
this week, but I do think
it's important to soak it up
and as they say "enjoy the journey not
"just the destination."
I learned a valuable lesson
when I was a freshman
at Tennessee that I
applied to my first year on
the job in the NFL.
It was the first time I
ran into the huddle as
a quarterback in Tennessee.
We were playing up at UCLA
at the Rose Bowl, 95,000
people in the stands, ABC
broadcasting the game on
national television, Keith
Jackson and Bob Greasi.
Tennessee was ranked ninth
in the country, UCLA was
unranked, expected to be a blowout.
I was 13 on the depth
chart not expecting to play
the entire game much
less the entire season.
On the second play of the
game our starting quarterback
tears his knee, he's out for the year.
Our backup quarterback was
a guy named Todd Helton
who went onto have an 18
year major league baseball
career, let's just say Todd
was kind of thinking about
that baseball signing
bonus he was about to get,
he wasn't real crazy
about going into the game.
So we're getting to be 21 to
nothing, my coach turns to
me and says "Peyton, you're going in."
And boy I didn't think I was
nervous, I looked down and all
the hair on my arms was
juts sticking straight up.
So I got into that huddle, and
I remembered something that
my daddy told me, he said
"son if you ever get into the
"huddle with the stars at
any point in the season,
"it may be in the fourth
quarter blowout, it may be just
"in practice, it doesn't
matter, you be the leader
"and you take control of that huddle.
"That's your job as the
quarterback, you're just 18
"years old, most of these
seniors are 21, 22, it doesn't
"matter, be the leader and
take control of that huddle."
So I remembered old Dad's advice
and I get into that huddle,
and I said "alright guys,
I know I'm just a freshman
"but I can take us down the
field right now, get us a
"touchdown, get us back
in this game, let's go!"
Big left tackle, a guy named
Jason Layman, about six
five, 330 pounds, grabs me
by the shoulder and says
"hey freshman, shut the blank up and
"call the blanking play."
(laughing)
And I said "yes sir."
That was really great advice from my dad,
I really appreciate that.
Well I've always had a passion
for the game, but when you
are out for a year you
certainly miss certain things.
Being in that huddle, flying
back on the plane after
a big victory, the weight
room and after practice
throwing sessions with your
receivers, they're going to
make a difference and help
you win a game on Sunday.
You just don't get to
participate in those activities
when you're not playing
and you're injured.
So to get back out on the
field I had more of an
appreciation for the little
things, everybody enjoys
playing football in the
games, but I have more of
an appreciation for the small
details, the things that you
won't get to do after you
stop playing football.
So those moments have
been even more special.
In my very first NFL game I
completed my first pass to
hall of fame running back Marshall Fall.
I threw a touch down in that
same game to Marvin Harrison,
who would inducted into the
hall of fame this August.
The quarterback for our
opponent, the Miami Dolphins
was after my dad, my favorite player,
hall-of-famer Dan Marino,
who won the first third
down of the game, completed
a 25 yard skinny post,
and it was the damnedest
throw I've ever seen.
Later I completed a pass
to tight end Marcus Pollard
down the middle, and somebody
hit me really hard and after
I got up I told myself "I know
I can play in this league."
Later in that struggling
season, we played in and lost
to Baltimore, it was the
first time that the Colts had
returned to Baltimore since
they had moved in 1984.
We didn't exactly get a
warm reception that day.
Fans were screaming at
me and I was thinking
"hey I was only eight years
old then, get off of my back."
I had met him once before
but when the game was over
I had a chance to shake
Johnny Unitas's hand.
He told me "Peyton, you stay
at it, I'm pulling for you."
Well, I have stayed at it,
I've stayed at it for 18 years.
And I hope that old number 19
is up there with his flat top
and maybe his black high tops on.
And I hope he knows that I
have stayed at it and maybe
he's even a little proud of me.
- Because now it's all
about money, it's all
"let's get out and play
and make the millions,"
because you don't know what
could happen in that final year.
- Right, that's kind of the
norm now, people take the
money and go pro, but just
growing up around college
football I always loved the
game, and my dad loved to play.
He juts taught me to play
for the love of the game,
and that's really what I do.
I like to play the game
and I want to come back and
play another year of college football.
- [David] Well good for you.
- And I told our editors Chris
Stone and Paul Ficktenbaum
a story about last year after
one of the most crushing
defeats of your career,
right here in this stadium
against the Baltimore
Ravens, that you waited for
about 15 minutes afterwards,
with your wife and with
your son for Ray Lewis to come out.
Why'd you do that?
- Well Ray Lewis has been
the greatest defensive player
that I've ever played against,
and I knew that was going to
be his last game and you just
don't cross paths with those
players once they stop playing.
So it was definitely a
disappointing night but I thought
it was the appropriate thing
to do to go over and pay
respect to one of the greatest
defensive players of all
time and the best player of my era.
And took the moment and
I was glad that I did it.
I played the Ravens this
year, it wasn't the same not
seeing number 52 over there,
I haven't seen him since
that moment and realized
that I won't see him quite
as often, so I guess that was
an example of sportsmanship,
it certainly wasn't easy,
I can promise you that.
But I was glad that I
did it because I thought
he deserved my respects.
I look back on my NFL career,
I know without a doubt
that I gave everything I
had to help my teams walk
away with a win.
There were other players who
were more talented, but there
was no one who could out prepare me.
And because of that I have no regrets.
There's a scripture
reading, second Timothy 4:7,
"I have fought the good
fight and I have finished
"the race, I have kept the faith."
Well I have fought a good
fight, I've finished my football
race, and after 18 years it's time.
God bless all of you,
and God bless football.
A hard hit or not, I don't
believe there's any way to
overprepare for your future.
Have a formidable plan,
have a backup plan,
and have a back up to your backup plan.
My preparation began by
watching game tape of our
team and competitors.
It helps me put the pieces
of the puzzle together.
Years ago I had a system put
in my house where I could
analyze every game, every
competitor, without having
to go into the team's practice facility.
So if you ask me how long do
I watch game film to prepare,
I couldn't tell you because
I never kept a clock.
I just watch until I feel
ready, I watch and I prepare.
I can actually get lost
in the intense focus of
figuring things out that
other may never even look at.
If you really want to be
a game changer out there,
become a master observer.
Just the willingness to
stop and look at things that
no one else has even bothered
to look at, enables game
changers to identify
real points of meaning.
The simple process of focusing
on things that are normally
taken for granted, can
be a source of great
power and creativity.
I'm a naturally curious
person, I want to know and
thoroughly understand things.
We learned and we observed,
we'd pick up on clues,
we figure things out, that is
what preparation is all about.
(shouting)
- [Reporter] Manning uses
a rare form of Gaelic at
the line of scrimmage.
(shouting)
- I mean we all speak
regular Gaelic, but Peyton's
kind of into his own thing, you know?
Takes me forever to translate it.
(shouting)
- How do you decipher any of it?
- Well he's been sticking
his hand up my butt
for 11 years, so we're pretty close.
(shouting)
- My brother Cooper
actually is the one who
taught me Gaelic.
He's really into it, he's got
a personalized license plate.
- What does it say "Mr.
Gaelic" or something?
- Why you making fun of my brother?
This Gaelic stuff's awesome
but I like to mix it up
every now and then.
A lot of times I just say
whatever comes to mind.
Bacon bacon bacon!
Hot sauce, hot sauce!
Taco taco!
- I don't know what that means.
- [Peyton] Bacon bacon bacon!
- I don't know what the
guy's talking about most
of the time, I just run
an out route and just hope
he throws it to me.
- Chili chili chili!
- What?!
- Taco, taco, taco!
A lot of times Kenny, we
have no idea what we're doing
but the defense doesn't
know that we don't know what
we're doing, and that's next level.
(shouting)
Ice cream alert, 654 Jose!
Okay, or nothing!
- [Reporter Two] Peyton
Manning and the Colts, from the
NFL's most sophisticated offense.
Each play can be called
or changed at the line.
That forces the Colt's
lineman to wait and wait
until Peyton finally makes up his mind.
I wonder if they ever think
"just snap the damn ball!"
- Check brown, Richmond,
96 double 96 double!
Run a flare run a flare!
- [Mike] His goal's not
to get the perfect play,
it's to get out of a bad play.
And more times than not they do that.
- [Announcer] Peyton drops,
look, fire, touchdown
making it rain!
- It's a ballet that drives
people crazy, I just say
"just snap the damn ball!"
They'll do it when
they're damn well pleased.
(shouting)
- It started way back I guess
kind of around my second
year with Tom Moore, we kind
of just sat down and put
some code words together
and things that kind of made
sense, but it has taken off from that.
First right, shore locks,
shore locks, shore locks!
Richmond, Florida, Buffalo!
37 double!
Louisville soul train,
Louisville soul train!
Purple, purple Buddha raiders!
It's not about trickery.
Purple Buddha raiders!
But it does take constat
communication because when you
do change a pass play to a
run, a run play to a pass play,
it's not easy as just, hey let's throw it.
It's I say something and
then you tell the offensive
line, they have an
entirely different language
that really nobody else understands.
It's unbelievable what
these guys go through.
Thinking about go ahead and block.
(screaming)
If you don't have linemen
that are smart, that can
like I said, just comprehend
it all with five seconds,
make their calls, call
east, west, slug, dumbo,
you name it, these words
that, you know what do these
words come from, what
other business requires
using words like that?
(saying random words)
- Bonanza, I mean that
really doesn't mean anything
but could be a call that
we use, I don't know.
(laughing)
- Could be, maybe not, not sure.
(speaking jibberish)
- It's not so much the coach
that needs to know what
we're talking about, it's
the players that need to talk
to one another, so we leave
a lot of their code words
and calls and that sort
of thing up to them.
That means that you may
have to do a scat right,
255, brip brip, scoop it.
- Hold on before you get in
there, we have to call bogus
on Howard Mudd saying he's not invovled.
- I said don't talk, let me talk!
- I'm glad somebody spoke up.
- That man is involved in
every part of every call
we will ever make.
- 51 made the play,
you know why, because--
- 93 made the play, 51 made the--
- That's exactly what
happened, I was right there!
- They need to be smart
and they need to be tough
minded, tough minded in that
they may only get a piece
of the information or they didn't get
any of the information.
- I remember in Kansas
City in the playoff game,
the left, neither of us knew
the play and we couldn't
hear, we just kind of ran
out and it turned out great.
- [Announcer] Hughes
goes off the left side,
cuts it up the middle,
and gets to the end zone!
Touch down!
- The way we talk about
it is you have to hear.
There's not an option "I didn't hear ya."
And if somebody doesn't hear,
I really feel responsible
and so that's why I
always kind of go back for
a second time, I go down
the line just to make sure
everybody knows what to do,
because if one guy doesn't
hear, that guy misses the
block and you have a bad play.
Water or green light?
- Either one.
- Green light, let's go green light.
- You can read through it
in your play book as much as
you want, but you're not
going to understand it until
you're out there on the field
actually hearing it come
out of the quarterback's mouth.
- Chin chin, point left, point left, 55!
- [Coach] There are times
when he calls the real play
and that changes it.
- Good job, Japan, Japan, Japan!
Japan Japan!
- There are times when
he calls a phony play.
(shouting)
To extract a reaction
before we call a real play.
- Lop lop, buffalo, lop buffalo 14!
- Then we have the fake play real play,
and then change the real play.
Sally 19, 19 Sally 19!
19 Sally!
- I like that he's changing
the play, because when he's
changing the play the defense
sees us looking at him
or looking at Jeff or
whoever, and they're just
as confused, I mean they
don't know when the ball's
going to be snapped, so a lot
of times they kind of relax
a little bit and wait for us
to get done communicating.
- They did a lot of guessing.
I mean they're trying to
guess what play we're running.
Listening to our calls,
oh when they do this this
is what they do.
- When they're behind his legs,
he's giving the finger first!
- Yeah he's giving them how
many times he's going to do it.
- [Tomas] When his leg goes
down, that ball is coming.
- If I were a defender,
listening to our calls wouldn't
be one of the big things for
me, because he's just one
of those guys that
he'll fake it or he does
his little gymnastics back
there and defenses bite.
So the whole "listen to the
words" hasn't worked yet.
- Fly left, fly left,
hippies mic, fly left!
- Really we don't get to
see a lot of of him because
he's orchestrating behind us.
- Behind the buffalo, hind to buffalo.
- But we hear from other
people like family or
friends, like "what is that!?"
- Apple apple inside, 54 54 54!
I think about quarterbacks,
their defining legacy,
you think about Dan Marino,
it's just the quick release.
From Ellway it's the
sprint right throw back
across the left.
Montana, it's the classic
throwing motion and
the two minute drives.
For me I think it's going
to be this, picking my nose,
ear, you know, this, all
these different things
that I do.
I don't know if I want that
to be my legacy but that
is what we have to do and
you're constantly having
to do something, either
tell the center something,
throw the tight ends, tell
the receiver, tell the backs.
It's what is required
of the quarterback to
get things communicated.
- [Mike] It's an amazing
compilation of people and schemes
and it works.
- Five 28!
- People say "just stamp the
damn ball" but again if you
look at the traffic since
Peyton's been there, it's been
a great orchestration that's worked.
- [Reporter Two] Because the
Colts can be more reactive at
the line than other teams,
they take fewer risks
and score more touch downs,
and perhaps that will
be the legacy of Peyton
Manning and his offensive line.
- [Announcer Two] Boy the
Colts are looking tremendous,
protection was excellent.
(celebrating)
- Thank you guys so much for
watching, I hope you enjoyed.
I made this video because
Arturo Menja asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave it
down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know, what
did you learn from Peyton
today, what was your favorite
clip, what message was most
meaningful to you, what are
you going to apply to your
business, leave it in the
comments below and I'm going to
join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
quick shout out to Ben Stucke,
Ben thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book.
It really really really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for
watching, I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourselves.
And whatever your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- I thought it was very
interesting when I saw you here
at training camp this summer,
one of the things I said
to you, I asked you a question,
what do you think you'll
be doing in 15 years?
And you wouldn't answer the
question, and I thought it
was so interesting.
Why wouldn't you answer that question?
- Well I think maybe had you
asked me two years ago I might
have had more of an idea but
like I said, these past two
years have truly changed
my life, and so I'm really
at a new place and kind of
in the second chapter of
my football career, and
I'm taking that chapter one
page at a time, and so it
feels so good to be back out
on the field playing this
great game, and I realized
after that injury, I think
I always have realized this,
but it was certainly reinforced
that next year certainly
is not promised, so I am
all in for 2013 and I'm
certainly enjoying this year.
♫ Crawfish shorts I like your style
♫ Hooked it just a little bit
(shattering glass)
♫ Don't open that cellar door
♫ Epic comeback starts right here
Lucky shot.
- [Narrator] He wore the number
18 but he is the number one
in all time passing yards.
The number one in all passing touch downs.
And the number one in--
♫ This smoke machine is really cool
- [Narrator] Yeah it's pretty great.
- Can I get some more smoke?
Perfect.
- Shall we say grace?
Heavenly Father.
- [Narrator Two] She
had the perfect family.
An adoring husband.
- Why you smiling?
- I don't know, I'm just happy.
- [Narrator Two] And an ideal life.
(laughing)
But she also had a dark secret.
She liked to collect...
Football players.
- Do you have any place to stay tonight?
- Yes I have a place to stay.
- Don't you dare lie to me.
- Lady I'm not lying, I'm Peyton Manning
I own a couple of homes.
- Come on.
- Fine, but only because
you're freaking me out.
- [Narrator Two] Now this quarterback...
- Oh and Sean says all the
pro athletes use futons
if they don't find a bed big enough.
I got you something nicer.
- [Narrator Two] Is in a
game of life and death.
- I never had one before.
- What, a room to yourself?
- No, a crazy lady holding
me against my will.
- Wel you have one now.
- [Narrator Two] Starring academy award
winner Sandra Bullock.
Mike?
- Eli, this is serious.
- [Narrator Two] And four
time NFL MVP Peyton Manning.
- This crazy lady is holding
me prisoner in her house.
- Big Mike?
- She keeps calling me "big Mike!"
Stop laughing, it's not funny.
- [Narrator Two] Was
she crazy about football
or just crazy?
- That's another thing,
we need to find more
about his past.
- But he won't talk about
it, he's like an onion
you have to peel him
back a layer at a time
- Not if you use a knife.
- [Narrator Two] She wouldn't
let anyone get in her way.
- Michael needs a B,
what does he have to do
to deserve that?
- First of all his name's
not Michael and he is very
clearly NFL quarterback Peyton Manning,
that would be him.
And second of all I can't
give him a B because of how
badly he's doing in class.
Let me read you his essay
about a tale of two cities.
"Help, please help me,
call the police, I'm Peyton
"Manning and I've been kidnapped
by the lady from Speed."
- Then that's it, we're sunk.
- We're sunk, no you're sunk.
Because you see I've contacted
the authorities and they're,
oh my God you've poisoned my coffee.
- [Narrator Two] See the film Archie
Manning called "terrifying."
Tony Dungy says "it's spine tingling."
And Bill Belichick raves "it's hilarious."
- We want to know if
you would like to become
part of this family.
- Let me ask your kids something, did she
kidnap you as well?
And if I say no something
terrible's going to happen to me?
So I guess my best bet
is to just pretend I'm a
teenager even though I'm 34.
Fine, I'm in.
Let's do it.
(laughing)
You okay kid?
Everything okay in there?
(evil laughing)
- [Narrator Two] The dark side.
- How's he doing.
- Hasn't quite gotten the hang of it yet.
- That's because I'm
playing offensive line,
I'm a quarterback!
Sorry Mama.
- [Narrator Two] In theaters never.
- Hey, you're Peyton Manning.
- No my name is Michael, Michael.
- [Narrator Two] The Dark Side.